we are now going to go to the east and
explore ancient China and we're going to
do that in the second millennium BCE
where we see some of the first great
dynasties of ancient China emerging so
if we go to roughly the 16th century BCE
so that would be about 3,600 years ago
we have the emergence of the Shang
Dynasty and what's significant about the
Shang Dynasty is it's the first dynasty
where we have significant archaeological
evidence of its existence we have a lot
of evidence in this area where you see
highlighted in red where the Shang
Dynasty existed with its capital at en
the modern date near the modern-day city
of Anyang now we have accounts of a
dynasty before it the sia or the Chia
dynasty although we do not have
significant archaeological evidence of
it but the accounts say that the Chia
dynasty would have been around for
roughly 500 years before we get to this
16th century BCE with the emergence of
the shang dynasty now just to get
ourselves acquainted in time and space
to think about well what else was
happening around 1600 BCE we could
remind ourselves that that was during
the New Kingdom in ancient Egypt right
around here the height of of ancient
Egypt's power was right around that time
we could think about the Hittite Empire
that we study in other videos we could
think about Mycenaean Greece around 1600
BCE is when you start having or when you
have the decline of the Indus Valley
Civilisation also known as the Harappan
civilization and you start to have the
Vedic period where you have these
indo-aryan of people start to migrate
into northern India in Mesopotamia you
have the Assyrian Middle Kingdom right
around here so this is all happening in
this
did too late second millennium BCE which
is roughly the time of the Shang Dynasty
now the Shang Dynasty was known for many
things
it was a Bronze Age culture and you can
see depicted here many examples of that
and this is pretty impressive work with
bronze this is a bronze battle ax right
over here you can imagine a handle a
handle for this ax something like this
this is not something that you would
want to deal with in in a battle and you
can see these other very significant
large bronze crafts for the handiwork
that that the shang dynasty was able to
produce now what the shang dynasty is
also well known for is their writing
it's the first evidence of a fairly
advanced writing form for and it's
related to modern chinese and a lot of
that writing the significant artifacts
from that time are on what are called
oracle bones that's an oracle bone right
over here this is actually the the
scapula the shoulder blade of an ox and
what they would do is they would write
questions in this Oracle bone script on
top of that scapula of an ox and then
they would heat it up in a flame or some
type of source of heat until it cracks
and then they would interpret the crack
to see what was the answer to their
actual questions and you can actually
see how this Oracle bone script is
related to modern Chinese script so this
is Shang written in Oracle bone script
and you can see how it evolved over time
to the modern-day Chinese script even
though if you go straight from that to
that they look reasonably different but
when you look at the evolution you can
see that there that they have a lot of
commonality you also see it in words
right over here shows the evolution of
the word tiger and once again this is
the Oracle bone script and you can see
it looks right here like a picture of a
tiger but then it evolved over time to
the modern form
over here now this Shang civilization is
no coincidence that first Asiya and in
the Shang that they develop over here in
the yellow river and the Yangtze River
Valley's we've talked about it
the ancient Egyptians the Mesopotamians
all of the Indus Valley the Indus Valley
Civilisation they all started where
agriculture first emerged was tend to be
in these river valley civilizations now
the Shang in particular not only were
they known for their bronze work there
were lot they were known for their large
cities they were known for their complex
social structures they were known
especially near the end of the Shang
period for having chariots and some
people think that because they had
chariots there might have been contact
with folks further west
now the Shang Dynasty I said how the the
Xie dynasty lasted for over 500 years
and the Shang Dynasty also lasts for on
the order of 500 years which is a very
very very very long time
but as we get to the middle of the 11th
century BCE we would it would reach its
end the last king of the Shang Dynasty
is this gentleman right over here this
would be d sin or d shin and the
accounts have him initially in his rule
as being a very capable ruler but later
in his rule he seems to get more corrupt
becomes less competent of a ruler his
fav his favorite consort dodgey right
over here she's a bit of a not so
popular figure in Chinese history a lot
of people think that she helped or they
blame her for corrupting D shin and so
he eventually faces his end in the
Battle of mu yi against King Wu of Zhu
or Jo is actually the correct pronounce
a king Wu of Jo and King Wu of Jo is
able to defeat B shin at the Battle of
mu yi and that is the end of the Shang
Dynasty and it begins the Jo dynasty
which will go on for another 800 years
it's pretty impressive how continuous
these dynasties actually are and after
that battle the shin goes off and
commits suicide and this right over here
is
fiction of king woo of Joe who starts
the Joe dynasty but the big picture
here's we're talking about huge swathes
of time and we have a significant you
guess you could say civilization is
started with the river valleys in China
but it's amazing how continuously
civilizations were and it's also amazing
how how modern their writing was
relative to modern Chinese script and
that's why historians believe that
writing of this form was because of how
advanced it was was probably in place
for a long time before we see these
oracle bones so even though we don't
have the strong archaeological evidence
yet for the Shia dynasty there's a lot
of evidence that by the time the Shang
came about the Chinese civilization was
already quite well developed around the
Yellow River and the Yangtze